you can see just like we had a look at a
product we use today we're gonna look at
the question rule today and we're gonna
actually unlike I'm just gonna hand it
to you we are going to prove this is
also I need to get you yet back into the
right context let's think about this
first
if you are differentiating the sum of
two functions what happens what do you
do with each of those two functions you
can yeah you can just do them separately
culture you can just say well I'll work
out the first derivative you - and then
I'll work out the second derivative V -
and the sum of sorry the derivative of a
sum is the sum of those two derivatives
and that's nice and neat so this is what
we call well the sum of function there's
nothing too complicated about it so it
doesn't get much of a special name but
then we said what if those two functions
instead of adding them together what if
you had a function with another function
inside it so for example instead of U of
X plus V of X what if you had you on the
outside and then what you put into there
was a different function like so okay
now this is what we call the chain rule
this was a bit difference so I'll just
give you a quick you know actual
concrete example right if I said 3x + 1
^ 7 right so you can see there you've
got this function inside 3x + 1 there's
your function inside there and then
you're applying another function to that
in this case raising it to the power of
7 right what did we do what was our
rules um I showed you a picture what was
the picture I know we'll come to that in
a second think about this this is the
babushka dolls do remember it's all
listed inside that's why I've written it
in this way so what we do is we just go
from the outside and we differentiate
every layer it I kind of think about how
would we write this okay here's the
outside function the one on the on the
most exterior part or what I write yeah
yeah
ah very okay so it comes in that in a
second actually you know what
I'll do that way that you've that you're
suggesting I'll do it first because that
is the old way we read it so you said dy
on D you and then you multiply that by
we chained it along with another
derivative do you um DX and that's why
you saw those do yous cancel okay but
underneath this I want to show you how
to write it in function notation so this
is what I started to write them let's
actually do it properly so if what the
thing was that I was differentiating was
a function on the outside and then
another function on the inside of that
let's think about how we rewrite this
but using this notation okay the outside
function that's this first thing here
right it's going to be differentiating
this guy right that's you - so in this
case what would that be what would be
the derivative of the outside function
hold on that's the outside function
there right so if I'm differentiating
this the seven comes out the front right
you still have this 3x plus one and then
what happens that power very good it
drops down so just before we blew on
bless you what you've done is you've
done you - but then say the inside is
not X its whatever the original inside
function was is still there right so
here I'm going to write that inside
function here is V of X in there okay
but I'm not finished am i that's just I
open up the booze guitar and I'm like oh
wait there's another function inside so
what would you do what's the next step
yeah three very good that's the inside
derivative there 3x plus one that gives
you the DVD so how do I write this in
function notation what's the name of the
inside function that that's the inside
function there so what would I call the
derivative of that I call it V - right V
- they go so these two things are saying
the same thing but we're using this is
Leibniz notation do you ever that it's
one of the reasons why we introduced it
and this is using the dash notation that
we started with at the beginning of
calculus all right Shanker is ahead of
us one
thing instead of the addition of
functions the other thing we looked at
was when you multiply functions together
so if I am differentiating one function
let's call it U multiplied by another
function let's call it V this is what we
call the the Veuve right after what the
letters were in order so if I just
spelled that out the first thing is V
multiplied by U - there's a derivative
there that's important plus the other
function the N and then V - very good so
we didn't prove this result it is a bit
of a it's a bit of a tangle to prove it
however we're going to use it now to
think about what happens if we don't add
functions if we don't multiply functions
what happens if we divide functions okay
so underneath this we're going to get
this result what happens when the thing
you're differentiating is not u plus me
it's not u times me it's u divided by V
okay so here's what we're going to do
we've said this dozens of times
throughout this course you guys know how
we often advanced mathematically by
taking a new problem and stating it like
it were an old problem and this is the
one reason why I sort of wanted to
review this with you not just because
it's fresh but also because we can get a
result for this we will get a result of
this on the basis of what's written
above on the board right this is a
question right so it's like something
divided by something else I don't have a
rule for questions yet
but every question it like 3/5 can be
written as a product I just have to
choose the right numbers what numbers
could I multiply together that would
give me the same as 3 over 5 what
numbers could have multiplied together I
want to multiply things I want something
times something else
hmm
whatever five times three everyone I'm
just going to write that as 3 okay now
you might think well that's a bit
trivial isn't it like of course those
two are the same thing
but importantly I have changed a
question into a product I know how to
deal with products so let's have a go at
this right I am going to say consider Y
being this over this okay so I'm writing
it as it starts as a question but now I
want to rewrite that as a product
because I can deal with products right
so I'm going to write that as u over X
and a multiply that by 1 over V of X 1
over V of X now hopefully the astute mo
you will have said but wait a second
that's also a question like 1 over v is
also a question can I write that in
another way
whatever v so it doesn't look like a
question I just want to dress up the
same thing different way yeah very good
I could write this as 3 times 5 to the
minus 1 I can do the same thing over
here so I'm gonna write this in a big
set of brackets here V of X to the
negative 1 ok now why is this any better
than what I had before
well you know how I said I've got a pro
- you got a protein we'll have a look at
just this guy here forget about the rest
of the question just focus your eyes on
this do I have a rule have I developed a
rule that can help me differentiate
something like this is this is this here
is it a product by itself is not being
multiplied by anything I've seen times
in there but just have a look like I
gave you what did we have a look at
three X plus ones that have seven right
and then you gave me what rule for this
the chain rule right all right well
let's just change this number here this
7 what if it were for instance negative
1
yeah you would do exactly what you did
before just with negative one instead of
seven and then off you go
so in other words you can use the chain
rule on this we can use the chain rule
on this does this make sense okay so I'm
gonna this is tricky because I'm gonna
try to do both the product rule and the
chain rule at the same time let's have a
go for starters the first thing I need
is V that's the first thing that's
written in the product rule so here is
that second thing over there so I'm just
going to write that as it is so let's
write it let's see here V of X took have
negative one what's the next thing that
comes along yeah you - now my U is just
called you so I'm just gonna write you -
there you go that's the first half of
the product rule so far so good
plus what's the next thing alone just
look carefully I've already done you -
so the next one along I love to hear now
it's just you write so I'm just gonna
write that you now here comes the tricky
part we have to think carefully this
part right
the last bit in the product rule is V -
so see this thing I've highlighted in
red I need to differentiate that whole
thing including the minus one can we use
the chain rule here okay let's think I'm
gonna do the outside first right what
happens that negative one just comes out
the front so I'm gonna write that
negative one then what happens to the
negative one doesn't stay like that does
it it's going to drop down by one drop
down by one so let's see I'm gonna write
that as V of X naught to the power of
negative one but to the power of
negative two very good and that's just
the outside now I have to handle the
inside
what is the inside function here it's V
there it is right there so what's the
derivative what would I call the
derivative of this guy just call it V -
okay now know this looks like a bit of a
garbled mess but we've done all the hard
work now we just need to tidy this up
algebraically why did I introduce the
negative indices I don't have it on the
very first line why'd I do that
so to make it not a fraction because
then I can differentiate it which I have
now successfully done so now that I've
done my differentiation I don't need
these as negative indices anymore so I'm
going to get rid of all of the negative
indices I can see how would you rewrite
this yeah it's one over V of X is that
okay that then there's au - then there
is okay let's have a look here whoops
I'm not gonna write a plus because that
sign has changed what's in the middle
now it's a minus because of that
negative one - okay let's see here now
I've got on the numerator let me
highlight this with some color on the
numerator of my fraction I've got a U
and a V - do you see that yeah so I'm
gonna write those U and then V - what
does my denominator become I want to get
rid of this negative index that I can
see yeah it's it's one over this squared
right so in fact I'm gonna write that as
V V of X sorry that should be a square
bracket squared is that okay alright I
can do a little bit of tidying up here
you know how in my product alright just
to make it a bit easier to write
I didn't write of X of X of X of X right
it's still there kind of in the
background but I just wrote it without
that to make it easier I'm gonna do the
same thing here I've got you - on V that
alright that's just me tidying up that
first one over here I've got UV - on I'm
just gonna call that V squared so our
two fractions what do you normally do
when you see two fractions what are you
searching for when you want them to
operate your common denominator what
might you suggest would be a helpful
common donut in this case just yeah just
multiply this guy by V and we'll have a
V squared here V squared there let's do
it what do we get on the left hand side
here I could write as u - V I could do
that but you know what I think I'm gonna
write it as the fee first even though
it's not alphabetical and then the u - V
u - that'll be divided by V squared
I should write then and then I've got
this guy here
can we put this together in one fraction
now what will the numerator be the
numerator I'm just gonna I've got the
same denominator don't know so I can
just put these two things together v u -
at the front - UV - does that look
familiar and then we divide everything
of course by V squared okay so this is
why yesterday I said you could call this
an overview if you want because in
addition you can change the order but
the reason I left it as a vu - out of
alphabetical order it's so that you
would have less to remember the product
rule and the quotient rule are so very
similar which shouldn't surprise us
because we use the product rule to get
to the question rule but this guy is
different it is a little more
complicated this that's really naughty
of me sorry this is the derivative that
we've just calculated okay so what I end
up with here is you want to put this
back in your original line where you've
got all your rules all together V u - -
u v - all over V squared that my friends
is the quotient rule okay so it's kind
of nice that at least it's not too much
in your memory that's different it's a
little bit like the relationship between
the cosine rule and Pythagoras like oh
these are built off the same stuff